JONATHAN: Good
morning, and welcome
to Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, it's my great pleasure to
introduce Doctor Alan Lightman
who's here to discuss
his most recent book,
"The Accidental Universe: The
World You Thought You Knew".
I could easily spend the next
10 minutes detailing his CV.
But in the interest
of time, I'm just
going through out a
bunch of things from it.
Novelist, essayist,
physicist, educator, professor
of science and writing
and senior lecturer
in physics at MIT.
Co-founded the graduate program
in science writing at MIT.
Co-founded the catalyst
collaborative at MIT.
A collaboration between MIT and
the underground railway theater
of Boston.
Distinguished physicist
and accomplished novelist.
First professor at MIT to
receive a joint appointment
in the sciences
and the humanities.
His novel, "Einstein's Dreams",
was an international best
seller and has been
translated into 30 languages.
His novel, "The
Diagnosis", was a finalist
for the 2000 National
Book Award in fiction.
He founded the
Harpswell Foundation,
a nonprofit organization
whose mission
is to empower a new
generation of women leaders
in Cambodia and the developing
world, and on and on and on.
He's also married to Jean
Lightman, one of the absolutely
most talented and notable
painters in Boston.
And that's barely
scratching the surface.
Please join me in
welcoming Alan Lightman.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Thank you.
Thank you, Jonathan.
It's very nice to
be here at Google.
And I'm especially
grateful to you
for mentioning my wife who
is a wonderful painter.
I went to Google a few years
ago to your Mountain View
headquarters and
gave a talk there.
And I've always been
a great fan of Google.
My talk today is going to be
a little piece of my book,
"The Accidental Universe".
It's going to deal with
science and religion.
And I'm going to first
briefly summarise
some of the high
points of science
over the last few
centuries that touch
upon theological, philosophical,
and ethical issues.
The main trend of science over
the centuries is, as you know,
has been to enlarge
the domain of what
we call the physical
universe and to provide
material and rational and
scientific explanations
for most phenomena in
the physical universe.
After that, I'm going
to turn to religion.
And I'm going to discuss
the kind of religious belief
that is compatible with science,
which does not necessarily
involve or require
a belief in God.
I'm going to talk about the
different kinds of knowledge
that science and religion have
and the differences in the way
that they obtain that knowledge.
And finally, I'll
talk a little bit
about what I will call
the spiritual universe.
And I will define exactly
what I mean by that
and suggest that there is
a spiritual universe that
exists alongside the
physical universe.
Let me start with biology.
And one of the leading
paradigm beliefs
in biology for centuries has
been really a controversy
between two different views.
The view of what we can
call the mechanists who
believe that
everything in the body
is just a matter of springs
and pulleys and weights
and that you can
understand everything
about the body in terms
of physics, chemistry,
and biology.
A purely material
view of the body.
And then there are
the vitalists who
have believed that there is some
additional non-material essence
of the body in the
body that provides
energy and spirit and so on.
Plato, Aristotle,
Descartes, were vitalists.
The first mechanist
was Baruch Spinoza.
And if any of you know his
work, you will know for sure.
You will certainly understand
that he was a mechanist.
In the 1800s, a
German physician named
Julius Mayer proposed that all
of the energy needs of the body
can be provided by food.
That is a purely
material explanation
for the energy use of the body.
And a little bit later, a German
physiologist-- Max Rubner--
did some experiments.
What he did was he looked
at the energy requirements
of the body both in motion
and just in generating heat.
Everything that requires energy.
And he tabulated that up.
And then he compared it to
the energy content of food.
And he concluded, looking
at a number of people,
that the energy
demands of the body
were, in fact, completely
supplied exactly by the food
that we eat.
So this is a purely
material explanation
for energy uses of the body.
Of course, another
major development
of biology that everyone
knows is the discovery of DNA
and the structure
of DNA, which is
a material explanation
for the command
and control and
reproduction of the body.
Here's an example of
a particular string
of genetic code that codes
for 9 amino acids with three
molecules needed to
specify each amino acid.
We now know, of course, that not
all the information in the body
is given in the genes that there
is environmental aspects where
the environment of the body
and actually experiences
can alter genes by either
turning them on or turning them
off.
So it's a more
complicated picture
that we have now than we
did in the 1950s and '60s.
But still, it's a purely
material understanding
of the command and control
and production of proteins
and so on in the body.
If we move to the brain,
of course, the mind,
body debate has been a
major philosophical debate
for centuries
whether the mind is
something separate
from the body.
We now understand
or most scientists
believe that the mind is really
nothing more than the material
action of the brain,
the set of neurons,
and the communication
between neurons.
As you know, the brain has
about 100 billion neurons.
And each one of them has
1,000 connections, roughly,
with other neurons.
We now know how
information is stored
in the neurons, both short term
memory and long term memory,
as a result of work
by Eric Kandel.
We know how the brain is able
to pay attention to things.
When we're paying
attention to something
and ignoring something
else, the neurons that
are paying attention,
their electrical impulses
all become synchronized with
each other like, of course,
singing in unison.
So we have learned quite
a lot about the way
that the brain functions at
the neuronal level and even
the molecular level.
There still is, of course,
a tremendous amount
that we don't know.
We don't really understand
consciousness, sort of,
the higher cognitive functions.
Many biologists believe
that even consciousness
will eventually be
understood in terms
of the actions of
individual neurons.
It's only a matter of time and,
in fact, Google may actually
be involved with this
before we have creatures
that are part machine
and part human.
And of course,
that will bring up
many philosophical
and ethical issues.
If I just go back to
the brain for a moment,
there's a question of one
of the other longstanding
philosophical questions is
do we have free will or not.
Are we free to make decisions?
And now that we know the action
of the brain at the level
of individual
neurons, the question
is what does freedom
really mean when you're
looking at individual neurons?
We still believe, of course,
that there's cause and effect
relationships in
the material brain.
But what does it mean
to ask the question
do we have freedom of choice
at the neuronal level?
So there's still a lot
of questions that remain,
even though we have a
largely material explanation
for everything in the
body and in the brain.
So let me turn now to physics.
And one of the-- Lucretius
was a Roman poet.
But I also thinking
of him as a physicist
because he was one
of the first people
to put forth the atomic
view of the world, which
is that everything is made
out of indestructible atoms
and the properties
of materials derived
from the shapes and the
textures of individual atoms.
It was really a causal
material explanation
for all of the phenomenon
in the universe.
And Lucretius really was
one of the first people who
had the concept of
a law of nature.
And what I mean
by a law of nature
or the laws of
nature-- first of all,
there's the idea that
nature obeys laws.
Secondly, that those laws
are quantifiable, usually
in terms of mathematics and
apply everywhere in the cosmos.
And finally, that the laws are
discoverable by human beings.
And that last point is,
of course, very important.
Galileo was the first
scientist to put forth
a quantitative law of
nature, a mathematical law.
And that was his law
of falling bodies,
which he proposed in 1590.
And that is that the time
that it takes an object
to fall a certain
distance-- I mean,
the distance that an object
falls in a certain time
is proportional of
the square of the time
that it's been falling.
So in one second, it
will fall one foot.
In two seconds, it
will fall four feet.
In three seconds, nine feet.
Something-- that's
the mathematical form.
Of course, if you put a
ball on an incline plane,
it will fall at a
different speed.
But it will still follow
this law of fallen bodies
that the distance fallen is
proportional to the square
of the time that it's falling.
This was a quantitative law.
And it was a special case of
Isaac Newton's law of gravity.
And of course, one of the
great things that Newton did
is he proposed that
gravity on Earth
works the same as
gravity in the cosmos.
That the laws in the
cosmos are really
the same as the laws on earth.
There's a single universal
law of gravitation
that applies everywhere.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
So by the end of
the 20th century,
we can say that
physicists had given us
the notion that there's a
strong connectedness of all
the phenomenon.
Earth and the heavens.
That everything obeys the
same universal physical laws.
So I'm going to turn now
and end with a few comments
about astronomy.
And of course, I'm going over
centuries of science very,
very quickly and just pointing
out a few of the highlights.
As you all know, the early
astronomers and scientists
believe that the Earth was
the center of the cosmos.
Very good physical
reason for believing so.
When we go outside at
night, we see the planets
and stars revolving around us.
So it's certainly
very natural to think
that we're at the
center of the cosmos.
Copernicus proposed
otherwise that it
is the sun at the
center of the cosmos.
A sun centered cosmology.
And one of the earliest
questions to come up
was how long has
the cosmos existed.
Has it existed
forever, or was it
created at a finite
time in the past?
This is a question,
of course, that
has both scientific and
theological reverberations.
The astronomer who settled
this issue was Edwin Hubble.
An American astronomer.
He was a Rhodes Scholar.
He was a boxer.
He had a law degree.
But instead of going into
law, he went into astronomy.
And around 1929, using
this telescope-- the Hooker
telescope; 100
inches in diameter;
the largest telescope
in the world
at that time on Mount
Wilson California-- Hubble
saw evidence for the
expansion of the universe.
What he saw was a
picture like this
with all the galaxies
moving away from each other.
And he didn't
realize exactly what
he was sitting at the time.
But combining his observations
with the theoretical work
of other astronomers, including
Einstein, we eventually
came to the conclusion that
the universe is expanding.
You can play that
movie backwards
with all of the
galaxies getting closer
and closer to each other.
And you can conclude
that the universe began
about 14 billion years ago
in a state of very, very
high density when all of
the matter of the universe
was crushed into a region
smaller than an atom.
And there are a
number of other routes
that we can get to that number
of about 14 billion years.
We can also date the
oldest stars that we see.
We can date the age of the
Earth from radioactive rocks.
And all of them give numbers
within a factor of two
that are consistent with
about 14 billion years.
And every time I think about
that discovery it just blows
my mind that we little creatures
here on this one planet
orbiting an ordinary
star in one galaxy
can figure out that our
whole universe began
at a certain finite
time in the past
and actually calculate
when that was.
That's just an
incredible accomplishment
of the human mind.
We actually have a
quantitative theory
for the universe from its
beginning 14 billion years ago.
And this, for
example, is a graph
of the temperature of the
universe from the beginning
to equal zero until now.
Each one of those marks on
the x-axis is a factor of 10
to the 10 different bigger or
smaller than the adjacent mark.
You can see that we are
very recent in this picture,
at least logarithmically.
The first planets were here.
The first atomic nuclei when
the universe was around a second
old, that's when the
first atoms began forming.
And we can trace the history
of the universe quantitatively
and mathematically all
the way back to about 10
to the minus 35 seconds.
And that is when
the universe went
through the so-called
inflationary period
where it began
expanding very, very
rapidly for just a tiny
fraction of a second.
We don't know what came before
10 to the minus 35 seconds.
That's an incredibly small time.
That's about one trillionth
of one trillionth
of one trillionth of a
second after the Big Bang
after t equals 0.
There's no way that we can know
what came before that point.
But we have some vague
notion that there
was a quantum foam
where universes
were materializing
out of a vacuum.
Some had the right properties
to begin expanding.
Some did not.
And they recollapsed.
And I've drawn those universes
here as little circles.
But that's just a metaphor.
We really don't know.
Between those little
spheres there,
space and time did not exist
because a universe creates
its own space and time.
So this is a hazy
area of physics.
What came before t
equals 0 in our universe.
We do think that there are
other universes that exist.
But this is an area
of extrapolation.
There's no way that we can
do any experiments to tell
what came before t equals zero.
So this is one of the areas
where science and religion come
together and philosophy.
So this is sort of
a good place to turn
to the intersection of
science and religion.
And I want to lay out a
little of the territory first.
I think that the areas where
science and religion overlap
or some of the areas
are the question
of what created the universe.
That's a question that science
will never know the answer to.
Are the laws of nature
sufficient to explain
the physical universe,
or do we need something
beyond the laws of nature?
Do we have free will?
This I touched on
briefly before when
discussing the behavior
of individual neurons.
So I think all of
these questions
are questions where philosophy,
theology, and science all come
together.
Some areas where I think
religion and science
are quite distinct and
have separate territories
and I'm just giving you a few.
I think ethics and
morality lies largely
within the theological domain.
Questions like the meaning of
life, I don't think science
can ever answer a
question like that.
I think that lies within
the area of theology.
A question of
whether God exists,
I think that lies
within religion.
I don't think that science
can ever prove or disprove
the existence of God.
On the other hand,
every issue dealing
with the nature of the
physical universe, I think,
lies squarely within
the domain of science.
Well let me talk briefly about
the kind of religious belief
that would be completely
compatible with science.
And before I do that, I
have to define something
that I call the central
doctrine of science.
And all scientists, most
of the time, believe this.
I think most of us believe
it all of the time.
And that is that all phenomenon
in the physical universe
are governed by laws.
And those laws apply everywhere
and at all times in a universe.
And if you're a graduate
student in biology or chemistry
or physics, your
thesis adviser may not
articulate the central
doctrine of science
specifically, explicitly,
but it's, sort of,
the working assumption
of all scientists.
So what kind of
religious belief would
be compatible with science
given this central doctrine
of science?
And to discuss that further, I
have to respectfully put forth
a working definition of God.
If God exists, certainly
we don't know what God is.
But for the purposes of
this discussion and as
believed by all
religions on earth,
God is a being who lives
outside of time and space
and is not limited by
the laws of nature.
And that is one
facet of God that
is subscribed to
by all religions.
So having gone
through all of that,
then we can say that science and
religion are compatible if God
does not intervene in
the physical universe.
And note that it is
not necessary to deny
the existence of God to
have this compatibility.
It's just that if
God does intervene,
that would violate the
central doctrine of science.
So you can believe in God as
long as God, sort of, sits
on the sidelines once
having created the universe
and does not intervene
and perform miracles.
And that kind of
belief is completely
consistent with science.
Science will never
be able to rule out
that kind of religious belief.
Most organized
religions do not uphold
the central doctrine of science.
Most of them have
Gods that intervene
in the physical universe.
For example, in Judaism
and Christianity, just as
one example, there are the 10
plagues that fell upon Egypt.
In Islam, Muhammad
split the moon in two.
And in Hinduism, the various
reincarnations of Vishnu
are constantly coming to
Earth and interacting.
So according to the
very specific criteria
that I've given, most religions
are incompatible with science.
Despite this, the
actual situation
and the actual
situation of beliefs
is much more complicated.
I've given a very
black and white set
of criteria and boundaries.
But the situation is more
complicated than that.
If we find evidence
of a law of nature
that is being violated-- that
seems to be being violated--
does that mean that God
has intervened or does
that mean that we have
incomplete knowledge
of that law of nature
and need to learn more?
For example, we believe that
the law of energy conservation
was being violated in the
1920s in a certain kind
of radioactivity
called beta decay.
Did that mean that
God was intervening?
Well, a few years later,
various scientists
postulated that there
was an existence
of another type of particle
called the neutrino, which
was carrying away
the extra energy.
And we found a neutrino
a few years after that.
That's just an example
of the uncertainty
when a law of nature
appears to be violated.
And I should say also that
in terms of personal beliefs
that there are many
non-scientists who
believe in an intervening
God but yet who also
place much value in
science and technology.
Every time we get
in an airplane we
are trusting in
the laws of physics
to keep that plane aloft,
whether we believe in
and intervening God or not.
On the flip side of
the coin and this
is what's most
interesting to me,
there are a number of
distinguished scientist-- maybe
5% or so-- who believes
not only in God
but believe in an
intervening God.
About 25% of all
scientists believe in God.
And about one fifth
of those actually
believe in an intervening God.
One such scientist here-- a
colleague of mine at MIT--
is Ian Hutchinson who is
professor of nuclear science
and engineering at MIT.
And he told me and I'm
going to quote from him,
"The universe exists
because of God's actions.
What we call the laws of
nature are upheld by God,
and they are our description
of the normal way
in which God orders the world.
I do think miracles take place
today and have taken place
over history.
I take the view
that science is not
all the reliable
knowledge that exists.
The evidence of the Resurrection
of Christ, for example,
cannot be approached
in a scientific way."
And here's another
scientist, Owen Gingerich,
who is professor
emeritus of astronomy
in the history of science
at Harvard University.
And he says, I quote, "I believe
that our physical universe
is somehow wrapped within
a broader and deeper
spiritual universe in
which miracles can occur.
We would not be able to
plan ahead or make decisions
without a world that
is largely law like.
But those laws do not apply
to all events", end quote.
So you can see the situation
is fairly interesting in terms
of what we actually believe.
And I think that devoutly
religious scientists such
as Hutchinson and
Gingerich-- that 5%--
reconcile their belief in
science with their belief
in an interventionist of God by
adopting a worldview in which
the laws of physics, chemistry,
and biology apply most
of the time.
But once in awhile, God
can intervene and violate
those laws.
And these exceptional, divine
actions cannot be analyzed
by the methods of science.
Well, let me say a little bit
about the nature of knowledge
and science versus
religion and the way
that that knowledge is obtained.
And I'll say first that I think
a couple of key differences
in science and
religion-- first of all,
I think science proceeds
by measurement and proof
and religion proceeds by faith.
And I'll say a little bit more
about what I mean by faith.
But basically, it's a set of
beliefs that cannot be proved.
And science is impersonal
at the group level
and religion is more personal.
And in all of this
discussion, now I'm
going to be talking not about
organize institutional religion
but about the religious
beliefs of individual people.
Organize institutional
religion has
a lot of political
dimensions, social dimensions,
that I'm not going
to try to deal with.
So what are the kinds
of knowledge in science?
Well I would argue there are two
kinds of knowledge in science.
There the properties
of material things.
And there are the laws
that those objects obey.
And we can talk
about-- here's a golf
ball, for example,
a physical object.
I don't know whether
any of you play golf.
I'm a terrible golfer myself.
We can talk about the
size of the golf ball.
We can talk about its color.
We can talk about its texture.
The golf ball is an object that
lies outside of our bodies.
And we can also
talk about the laws
that that golf ball behaves.
For example, it behaves
Galileo's law falling bodies.
If we drop it, it
will fall a distance
that's proportional to
the square of the time
that it's been falling.
How do we come to discover
these physical properties
and the laws?
We come to discover them by
observation and measurement.
For example, Galileo discovered
his law of falling bodies
by rolling balls
down inclined planes
and then measuring
how long it took
them to fall a certain distance.
Of course, Galileo didn't
have a modern clock like this.
He probably used a water
glass or a pendulum.
But he was able to measure
pretty accurately the time
that it would take for a ball
to fall a certain object.
And then, of course, Newton
had the more general law
of gravity, which explained
Galileo's measurements as a sub
case.
But Newton's law of
gravity was a little bit
off in explaining the orbit
of the planet Mercury.
Its orbit shifted by a
tiny fraction of a degree
every orbit that was not
accountable by Newton's
law of gravity.
And Newton's law of
gravity was eventually
replaced by Einstein's
law of gravity.
And this is the way
that science proceeds.
We have a theory.
We test the theory.
We believe it until
it begins to disagree
with certain more
refined experiments.
And then we modify
the law or develop
a new law, as was the case
with Einstein putting forth
his new law of gravity.
Einstein's law
gravity will probably
be modified as well because
we know that it does not
include quantum physics.
So this is the way that
science gets knowledge.
It's the way that it
tests it's knowledge.
And experiment is a critical
tool in obtaining and testing
knowledge and science.
It plays a critical role.
Now let me turn to
religion, which is probably
more interesting to
you since all of you
know the science well, I'm sure.
And first of all, what
do I mean by religion?
And I'm going to quote William
James who was the great Harvard
philosopher and psychologist.
And he wrote this
wonderful book in 1902
called "Varieties of
Religious Experience"
in which he talked to a
lot of different people
and tried to understand what
their religious beliefs were.
And what James says in the way
that he defines religion is,
"Religion consists of a belief
that there is an unseen order
and that our supreme good
lies in harmoniously adjusting
ourselves to that order."
And I think that
in this sentence
there are a lot of
important words.
Belief is very important
here because religion
is more about faith than
about physical evidence
and because it's more personal.
Unseen is important
because a lot
of the objects that religion
believes in are invisible.
And finally, the word good.
Our supreme good lies in
harmoniously adjusting
ourselves suggested there are
ethical and moral dimensions
to religious belief.
So I think James
definition of religion
captures all of the key aspects.
So what are the kinds of
knowledge in religion?
Well I would argue that
there are two kinds.
There might be more
but at least two kinds.
The first kind is the
transcendent experience.
And the second kind
of knowledge lies
in the content of
the sacred books.
And I want to say a
little bit about both
of those two kinds of knowledge.
By transcendent
experience I mean
the immediate and
vital experience
of being connected
to something larger
than ourselves and
the feeling there's
some unseen order in the world.
The transcendent
experience may or may not
involve a belief in God.
And I imagine-- well, I
should say first that to me,
as both a scientist
and a humanist,
that the transcendent experience
is the strongest evidence
that we have for a
spiritual universe.
I'm not going to
say evidence for God
but I will say evidence
for a spiritual universe.
And I'm going to define
that more as I go along.
But roughly, by
spiritual universe
I mean a group of human
experiences and feelings
that are not
completely analyzable
by the reductive
methods of science.
And I imagine that
many of you have
had a transcendent experience.
But I wanted to tell you one
that I had a few years ago
to give you an
idea of what I mean
by transcendent experience.
My wife is a painter, as
Jonathan mentioned earlier.
I am now mostly a writer.
And we spend our summers
on an island in Maine.
About 100 feet from our
house is a tall tree
that has an ospreys nest in it.
And every summer,
we watch the ospreys
go through their rituals
and their habits.
In April, the parents
arrive to the nest.
The mother lays the eggs.
Around beginning of June, the
eggs hatch and the baby ospreys
start growing up.
The father goes out and
catches fish for the babies.
The mother usually just
takes care of the nest
and takes care of the babies.
The osprey is a very large bird.
It's the second largest bird
there is after the eagle.
So it has a wingspan of about
this, and the nest is huge.
So my wife and I, we
watch these birds.
We take pictures.
We take notes.
We keep a journal.
And for years, we've sort of
documented their behavior.
This is just 100
feet from our house.
So it's like
watching reality TV.
We've learned over the years
how many babies they usually
have each season.
Usually two.
Sometimes three.
We know the different
calls that they make.
We know what the call sounds
for danger or for hunger
or for when food is
arriving at the nest.
The babies grow up
over the summer.
And usually around mid August
they take their first flight.
And until that
time, they've stayed
in the nest getting
bigger and bigger.
So my wife and I felt that
we understood these birds
pretty well.
And then, one summer
a few summers ago
it was an August afternoon.
I had been watching the nest
every day during the summer.
And our summer house
is a two story house.
And it has a circular
deck on the second story.
And I'd been standing on the
secular deck for maybe an hour
so every day
looking at the nest.
And I was about nest high.
So the birds were looking at
me as I was looking at them.
And I'm sure to them it looked
like I was in my own nest
because I was on
this circular deck.
So I'd been, sort of, looking
at these baby birds all summer
getting bigger and
bigger and bigger.
And then, one day in mid August,
they had their maiden flight.
The baby birds-- there
were two of them--
were finally large enough
to fly out of the nest.
And they took off.
I was standing on the deck.
And they did a very large loop--
maybe a half mile in diameter--
around the island
and then came back
and they started careening
straight towards me
as I was standing on the deck.
And they were coming
at very high speed.
And these birds now,
I call them baby
but they were big by this time.
And they have very
powerful claws
that they use for fishing.
And they could have
ripped my face off.
It was like two F15s
coming right at you.
And my first impulse
was to run for cover.
But instead I just
stood there frozen.
And the birds came right at me.
And when they were about 20
or 30 feet away-- very, very
close-- they did a very
high g acceleration
and went vertically up and
over the top of the house.
Before they did that a high
g acceleration and went
over the house, for about a half
a second we made eye contact.
And those birds were looking
at me straight in the eye.
And I don't know exactly what
happened during that half
second, but I felt like
we were communicating.
I felt like the
birds were telling me
we've been watching
you all summer,
you've been watching us, we're
brothers living on this land
together, and we
respect each other.
It was some kind of feeling
like that that I had.
And after they had gone, I
realized that I was in tears
and I was shaking.
It was such a
powerful experience.
There's no way that
that experience could
be analyzed by the methods
of science, in my opinion.
I think you could hook up MRI's
and CAT scans to my brain,
you can measure all
the electrical activity
of my neurons, and I
think it still would not
express the feeling that I
had for that half second.
I had connected with what I
call the spiritual universe.
It was a feeling
of being connected
to something larger than myself.
It was a feeling of
the unity of nature.
And that's what I mean
by the spiritual world.
It did not involve
any belief in God.
It was just this incredible
connection with nature
through these two wild animals.
Let me say a little
bit about the content
of the sacred books.
Of course, sometimes some
people take the content
of the sacred books as fact.
Some people take
it as a metaphor.
Some people take it
as the word of God.
I think that however you take
the content of the sacred books
that there's some
knowledge their.
It's knowledge of the feelings,
the mentality, the inspiration
of certain people who
wrote those books.
I would argue that any
statements in the sacred books
that deal with the
physical universe,
such as the age
of the Earth, fall
within the realm
of science and have
to be tested by the same means
as any other propositions
in science.
I'm almost finished with
the remarks I wanted to say.
I mentioned faith
a couple of times
and I wanted to say a
little bit more about that.
There are many things
that we take on faith.
Maybe you're not aware of them.
Without physical proof and even
sometimes without methodology
for proof we cannot show why
the ending of a novel haunts us
or why a particular character
in a novel haunts us.
We cannot prove under what
conditions we would sacrifice
our life to save the
life of our children.
We can't prove whether it is
right or wrong to steal food
to feed our families
or even prove
a definition of what
is right and wrong.
We can't prove what is
the meaning of our life
or even whether life
has any meaning at all.
These are all questions
where we can gather evidence,
we can debate them,
but there's no way
in which we can prove or
test any of these questions
in the same way that a physicist
can test how many seconds it
takes a ball to drop 10 feet.
These previous questions
are questions of ethics.
They're questions of
philosophy, morality,
they're questions for the
arts and the humanities.
And they're also questions
that religion deals with.
They're questions
of faith and belief.
I want to say something
more about the distinction
between the physical universe
and the spiritual universe.
Events in the end
the physical universe
can be recorded with rulers and
clocks outside of our bodies.
Those measurements provide the
evidence for what we believe.
Evidence in the spiritual
universe cannot be tested
and recorded in that way.
The evidence lies in
what we feel individually
person by person, such
as the experience that I
had with the ospreys.
The physical universe and
the spiritual universe
each have their own
domains of validity
and their own limitations.
The question of the age
of the earth, for example,
is a question that lies
within the physical universe.
We can date.
We can test the
age of the universe
by the radioactive
decay of rocks.
In contrast, questions like
did some intelligence create
the universe or is it moral to
kill people in times of war,
these questions lie outside
of the boundary of science.
They lie within the realm
of the spiritual universe.
And I am impatient with people
like Richard Dawkins or Sam
Harris or Daniel Dennett
who try to disprove
the existence of God with
scientific arguments.
I don't think that science
can ever prove or disprove
the existence of God
because if God exists,
as understood by
most religions, God
is not subject to
rational analysis.
God lies outside of
the physical universe.
And I'm equally impatient with
people who make statements
about the physical
universe that violate
physical evidence in the
known laws of nature.
I think that both science and
religion are seeking truth.
It's a different kind of truth.
In science, we're seeking
truth in the physical world.
In religion, we're seeking
truth in the spiritual world.
The experience that I
had with the ospreys
was a spiritual experience.
And after that experience,
I had discovered
what I think is a
truth about the world,
a truth about the
connectedness of life,
unity of nature,
and a truth about my own
emotional and psychological
being at that moment.
I think that science
and religion are both
seeking beauty.
Anyone who has worked in
science-- and of course, that
includes all of you guys--
know the beauty of an equation.
There's Galileo's law
of falling bodies, which
is a parabola, a
beautiful shape.
You know the beauty
of mathematics.
The beauty of science.
I think there's also a
beauty in the spiritual world
when we experience the
power and the subtlety
of human relationships
and human emotions
when we have this sense of being
connected to a larger world.
Some people believe that
there's only a single universe
that the physical
and spiritual are
part of the oneness of a unity.
This is an appealing idea.
According to this idea,
there's no distinction
between the outer and the
inner, between the subjective
and the objective, and
there's no distinction
between the miraculous
and the rational.
Although these are appealing
and compelling ideas,
I cannot accept them myself.
For me, both as a
scientist and humanist,
I need to make a distinction
between the physical
and the spiritual world.
For me, there is room
for both just as there's
room for both
science and religion.
Each universe has its own power.
Each has its own domain.
Each has its own
beauty and mystery.
And I'll end with just a comment
that a Presbyterian minister
made to me a year ago.
He said to me that science
and religion both share
a sense of wonder
and I would agree.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Do
we have questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes, please.
My name's Matt.
Great talk.
So in the beginning, we
didn't have much science.
We had beliefs.
Models, maybe.
And as science has
developed, it has disproved,
I think, some of those fictions.
Not all of them.
Science or our knowledge of
it has always been finite.
Always will be.
But I don't see that there's
a requirement that phenomenon
unexplained by science need
a fictional explanation.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yes, I agree.
AUDIENCE: Also, with the human
perception, we are fallible.
Right?
We know some people are crazy.
Even sane people can have
unreliable perceptions
momentarily or whatever.
So I don't think that this
transcendence personal
experience is really valid.
If it's not repeatable,
if it's not testable,
why should it have any weight?
I guess the crux
of my question is
why isn't the
burden of the proof
on the claimant for
spiritual notions?
ALAN LIGHTMAN:
Well, I don't think
they were trying to
prove anything here.
What I'm suggesting
is that there
are certain powerful,
emotional experiences
that we have that happen at a
qualitative level that are not
going to be explainable
in terms of the actions
of individual neurons.
It's not that I think that
something supernatural is
happening.
It's not that I think
that cause and effect
relationships are
being violated.
It's that I think that the
reductionist methodology
of science is not able to
capture the experience.
So that's what I mean.
And I don't think that that's
inconsistent with anything
that you said.
I'm not saying that what I call
a transcendent experience is
evidence for a
supernatural world.
AUDIENCE: You said that
the experiences like
your experience with
the eagle or the bird--
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yeah, right.
AUDIENCE: --are
evidence that there
is some sort of
spiritual universe.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Well it's a
spiritual universe within--
I'm rooting it in
the individual.
I'm not saying--
AUDIENCE: Well it's a metaphor
for a phenomenon, which
are too complex to analyze.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yes.
Yes.
So you might call
that another name.
I'm not saying that
that's evidence for God.
I'm not saying it's
evidence for a violation
of the laws of nature.
I'm saying that it is an
experience that many people
have had or many
such experiences that
are not going to be analyzable.
AUDIENCE: Even in theory?
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Well,
that's a good question.
Even in theory.
I do believe that everything
that happens in the brain
is a material phenomenon.
AUDIENCE: So then--
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yeah, I
thin that there are--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN LIGHTMAN: I think that when
I say even in theory I mean,
of course, I can't say
anything even in theory
because we don't know
what science is going
to produce 1,000 years from now.
But I think that
there are and I think
that sometimes the
physicists have recently
been giving a name to
some of these phenomenon.
They call them
emergent phenomenon
where there are phenomena
that can't be understood
in terms of the
individual parts.
And it's something like that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Leda.
Every so often, some
people come to my door
and promote a
particular religion.
And they ask me
if I'm religious.
And I say absolutely.
My religion is string theory.
And I just wanted to know
it seems to me that string
theory does, sort
of, touch both sides
of the spiritual and
physical world in the sense
that we have no way to test it.
And I'm just wondering--
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Well I think
that's a good analogy.
AUDIENCE: --what you think.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: I mean, that's
an example of something
that we believe in science as a
matter of faith without proof.
Those of us who believe
in string theory
believe it because
it unifies gravity
with the other three forces.
It's beautiful mathematically.
But you're right.
We can't envision any way
to test it at the moment.
I think Stephen Hawking's
boundary condition
for the beginning
of the universe
is another such thing that
we believe but is untestable.
The central doctrine
of science is something
that we believe and take
as a matter of faith.
But of course, the ways that
we obtain knowledge in science
are vastly different from the
ways that we do in religion.
So there are huge
differences, but I
think there are
matters of faith.
And string theory is
one of them in science.
So it's a good point.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One is about your
statement about
non-interventionist
deities, right?
What if the physical laws
are probabilistic in nature?
Like a radioactive
decay says that they
have to occur a certain
rate but the event
happens deterministically.
Is there room for intervention
in these little gaps?
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Right.
I mean, some thinkers
have said that that's
where God might intervene.
I don't really have
that view myself
because even though the
laws of quantum physics
are probabilistic, when you
have a large number of atoms,
you can make very accurate
predictions of the way
they're going to behave.
And if God was intervening
in those spaces
between an electron changing
orbitals and one atom
I think that that
intervention would
be visible on the
macroscopic scale somehow.
I don't think that
there could be
an intervention in a
violation of the laws
on the individual atomic
level in any kind of way
which wouldn't show
up from time to time
when you have a billion atoms.
So I agree that
that's a place where
you could have intervention.
But I don't subscribe
to that view myself.
AUDIENCE: And
briefly, I was going
to say your discussion of
transcending experiences
reminds me of Philip K.
Dick's story, "The Electric
Ant", where a man
goes in a hospital
and he finds out that
he's actually an Android.
And completely, his
world is upturned.
And then he opens
his chest, and he
finds a paper tape that
is his programming.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And he cannot resist
the urge to tamper with it.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yes.
I think that happened in one
of the episodes of Star Trek,
as well.
Data, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
share your belief
about the limits of
reductionism and this,
sort of, emerging phenomenon
being unable to be explained.
But I sometimes think about
the opposite question, right.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Can you talk
closer to the microphone?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes
I'm too tall.
I sometimes think about the
opposite question, right.
So in computer
science, you know,
we're starting to see neural
network algorithms, which
show emergent behavior
that we can't explain
in terms of these coefficients.
Like, it's just unexplainable.
There's too many
layers of networks.
Too many sigmoids stacked
on top of each other.
And I wonder if, you
know, given the way
you articulated your
thinking before, you think
there's space for a
spiritual universe of sorts
within that kind of
a computer system
when the computer's
powerful enough
to generate those networks.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Well I'm
hesitant to use the word
spiritual universe
because it's laden with so
many connotations.
But I do think that as
we're able to build computer
systems that have the
complexity of the human mind--
the human brain, I should
say-- with 100 billion neurons
and 1,000 connections between
each one-- every two of them--
that I think that there
will be phenomenon that
emerge that are
difficult to analyze.
I'll put it that way.
That doesn't mean that there's
something supernatural going on
or something magic or
anything like that.
It's just that the
complexity is so enormous.
And it may be that the question
of free will versus determinism
has that kind of
resolution, as well.
That even though
everything in the brain
happens completely according
to the laws of cause and effect
and eventually you can
track every action molecule
by molecule it could be that
the complexity is so enormous
that it's always impossible
to predict exactly what next
state you're going to be in.
If you start from
state A, where's
state B going to be
a second from then.
It may be just, for practical
purposes, an impossible
prediction.
And that may be what gives
us the illusion of free will.
It could be like that.
AUDIENCE: So you think that free
will means unpredictability?
It's an interesting thing that
a lot of people seem to believe.
But it's--
ALAN LIGHTMAN:
Yeah, I don't know.
I haven't read a really good
definition of free will,
and especially
when you're trying
to define it in terms of a
material assortment of neurons.
I think it's a great question.
I have heard a lot of
people say unpredictability.
But of course, if
you're a materialist
and you believe strictly
in cause and effect,
then there's nothing which
is completely unpredictable,
except when you take
in the quantum effects.
There's, you know,
a probabilistic.
So--
AUDIENCE: Depending
on when [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yeah, so
it's a great question.
I don't know the answer to it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the spiritual universe.
So if the spiritual
universe is outside
of the physical
universe, which I
think is what-- I hope I'm
understanding what you meant
earlier-- but it's
not supernatural,
how can it be outside of
the physical universe?
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Well,
that's a good point.
And I'm trying to make
a subtle distinction
that by spiritual
universe I mean
that it is a set of phenomena
human experiences that are not
completely analyzable or
understood stood by science.
It doesn't mean that something's
happening that's supernatural.
So maybe calling it
a spiritual universe
is not the best terminology.
But I try to define what
I mean by giving examples.
AUDIENCE: So 1,000
years ago there
might have been a
whole lot of things
in the spiritual universe
that have been plucked away.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Oh, definitely.
Yes, there's no
doubt that science
has brought within its folds
a lot of things that were once
considered supernatural.
AUDIENCE: Are you worried
science will completely
eliminate the spiritual
universe overtime?
ALAN LIGHTMAN: I'm not worried.
I think there will always
be a boundary between what
we understood.
But we can understand in an
reductionist manner and things
that we can't understand
in an reductionist manner.
That boundary may move.
No doubt, it shifts in time.
But I don't have the view
that we're ultimately
going to be able to
reduce everything.
And actually, I
think that mystery
is a good thing in science,
as well as the arts.
I think having a boundary
beyond which there are mysteries
is one of the
motivations of science.
And there's a wonderful
thing that Einstein said,
which is that the most
beautiful experience we can have
is the mysterious.
It lies at the cradle of
true art and true science.
And I think that when Einstein
used that word mysterious
he wasn't talking about
something supernatural.
He was just talking
about an unknown.
The unknown.
The awe of getting to the edge
of a cliff and looking over.
Something like that.
AUDIENCE: About ethics
being spiritual,
I wouldn't go as far as to
claim that ethics would be fully
encompassed by science
or that there's
laws of the universe
governing ethics.
I make no such claims.
But ethics are
testable, I think,
in that they're closer
related to governmental laws
and we can institute laws
and see how they work.
We can measure them quantifiably
to see what they do.
Now there's a framework of
how we say what's good or bad.
I mean, I'm not going there.
But ethics are testable.
And I don't think
that there necessarily
needs to be some spiritual
component to that.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Well, I
think we shouldn't group all
ethics into one lump.
I think a question like
is it OK to steal food
to feed your family or
is it OK to kill an enemy
soldier in time of war.
I don't think that those
questions are testable.
AUDIENCE: No, they are
testable because we
can have laws that
actually specify what
judges should do in [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yeah,
but that doesn't--
AUDIENCE: And see
what results from it.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: You could
have laws about anything.
I can have a law that
says God doesn't exist.
The fact that we
have laws about them
doesn't mean that we have
determined the rightness
or wrongness.
The laws just tell
us how we're going
to behave as a society for
people who do certain things
or don't do certain things.
But I don't think the
law answers the question
whether certain actions
are right or wrong.
They're just agreements about
how we're going to behave.
They don't answer the
question of right or wrong.
AUDIENCE: I'm simply
saying they're testable.
AUDIENCE: They're observable.
You can see what happens
in experiments that we've
had with different
societies across time.
We do this all the time,
actually, at Google.
We test, like, experiments on
people searches and whatever.
And there may be
ethical issues there.
I don't know.
But we can see the results.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Yeah,
but how are you
going to do a test to
determine whether it's
right or wrong to kill an
enemy soldier in time of war
or whether it's right
or wrong to steal food
to feed your family?
How are you going to?
AUDIENCE: There are laws
that address such behaviors.
AUDIENCE: How can
you tell [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: You can
observe the results.
AUDIENCE: And who observes?
What is the [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: We collectively
can observe the results.
And we can say whether
they're good or bad.
We do have a process
for coming to consensus.
It's ongoing.
It never ends.
And it's embodied in terms of
the set of laws that we have,
which I admit are
internally inconsistent.
And I mean, I wouldn't say are
all good but there they are.
And as a society, that's
what we have agreed upon.
Now previously our
society decided
that slavery was just fine.
So we're clearly
not always right.
But it's a process.
And we're getting
there, I would say.
ALAN LIGHTMAN:
Interesting comment.
Well I'll stick around
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Just curious
your thoughts around, like,
the existence of a heaven
or a hell type place
and the existence of them.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
ALAN LIGHTMAN: I didn't hear it.
AUDIENCE: Like, your thoughts
around the existence of heaven
or a hell type location.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: Oh, well I don't
believe in heaven or hell.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Never mind then.
ALAN LIGHTMAN: I mean, yes.
I think this is it.
Whatever we're experiencing
right now, this is it.
And this is all there
is, in my opinion.
But I don't know anything more
about this than any of you
guys.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]